en el último par de vídeos vimos que si
teníamos una matriz sé que fuera
cuadrada y de tamaño digamos n x en
donde además sus columnas sus columnas
es decir los vectores columna de esa
matriz forman forman un conjunto
junto [ __ ] normal y cuando digo [ __ ]
normal quiere decir que cada uno de los
vectores columna de esa matriz tienen
norma 1 y que además son ortogonales
entre sí entonces si tenemos una matriz
del estilo y que además se me olvidó
decirles el nombre de estas matrices
éstas tienen un nombre especial y son
las que se les conoce como matriz
ortogonal ok entonces una matriz
ortogonal es aquella cuyos vectores
columnas forman un conjunto corto normal
ok y de este tipo de matrices obtuvimos
un resultado muy muy interesante en
donde decíamos que la matriz transpuesta
era igual a la inversa de la matriz y
este resultado es muy bueno y realmente
lo que nos hace es que las cuentas las
operaciones de web se vuelven super
duper súper fáciles realmente esto es
muy útil en ese sentido a la hora de
estar en la práctica calculando algunas
cosas pero bueno el punto de este vídeo
es ver un poquito más de resultados de
este tipo de estas de estas matrices qué
eran transformaciones o que también los
podemos ver como cambios de base donde
la nueva base va a ser una base [ __ ]
normal y de hecho vamos a recordar un
poquito este tipo de diagramas quizás ya
estás hasta hasta el gorro de tantos
diagramas de este estilo pero el punto
es que sabemos que podemos ir de un de
este vector x podemos llegar a él a
partir de él mismo escrito en términos
de otra base esto sí lo hacemos
multiplicando por una matriz c
ahora bien podemos ir del vector x al
vector
x pero representado en términos de la
base c también multiplicando por una
matriz que en este caso sería la inversa
verdad esto simplemente es un cambio de
coordenadas de o por expresar este x en
términos de otros representantes de una
base muy bien entonces lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo
es mostrar una propiedad muy buena de
este tipo de transformaciones es decir
si transformamos todos los vectores del
espacio rn con una matriz ortogonal
vamos a tener que los ángulos y las
distancias se preservan entonces déjenme
déjenme anotar eso con palabras porque
no es muy matemático
se preserva
y ahorita diremos en qué sentido es que
se preservan distancias
distancias y ángulos
ángulos muy bien entonces cuál es el
sentido en el que estamos hablando de
preservar por ejemplo piensan piensan en
algún vector digamos un vector x digamos
que aquí tengo mi vector
x aquí está
y que tenemos algún otro vector no se
esté amarillito
entonces aquí se forma cierto ángulo
theta por supuesto nosotros vamos a
aplicar una transformación ce una
transformación dada por una matriz ce y
cuando nosotros aplicamos esta matriz si
yo digo que preserva distancias quiere
decir que este ángulo perdón este este
vector x podrá estar rotando sería hacer
muchas cosas pero su magnitud o su norma
debe ser exactamente la misma
aquí está el vector c x este es c x
y también cuando nosotros transformamos
el vector amarillo pues lo que debe
ocurrir es que el ángulo que forman
el ángulo que forma debe ser exactamente
igual bueno primero la distancia no se
vio muy bien que realmente se preservará
la distancia verdad pero el detalle es
que este ángulo de aquí debe ser
exactamente el mismo que teníamos
inicialmente entonces en ese sentido es
que estamos pensando que los ángulos se
preservan por ejemplo podríamos tener
alguna transformación que a lo mejor
haga esto
este es otro vector y tengamos otro
vector amarillo que haga esto entonces
este ángulo definitivamente no es el
mismo que este que teníamos así que esta
transformación
digamos este ejemplo que hicimos de
transformación no preserva ángulos
entonces esta de aquí no preserva
muy bien entonces ya que tenemos esta
intuición podríamos decir que en esencia
lo que está haciendo o más bien lo que
no está haciendo es distorsionar a los
vectores esto intuitivamente lo podemos
escribir que no distorsiona no
distorsiona vectores que no distorsiona
vectores eso es intuitivamente lo que
estamos diciendo y si ya tenemos esta
esta forma intuitiva de decirlo bueno
esto realmente no nos está dando una
demostración eso es lo que nos hace
falta demostrar que en efecto las
distancias y los ángulos se preservan y
vamos primero con las distancias que es
lo más fácil de demostrar tenemos que
demostrar que la norma o la longitud de
x debe ser la misma que después de
haberle aplicado la transformación esto
es lo que hay que demostrar y es y es
sumamente sencillo hacerlo tomemos la
norma de c x al cuadrado vamos a tomarlo
al cuadrado para poder expresar esto
como
x punto se x y lo primero que hay que
recordar es que cuando uno tiene una
multiplicación de este estilo
uno puede decir que no sé por ejemplo
tener
y punto y vamos a decir que tenemos que
calcular puntos y esto no es otra cosa
más que un producto de matrices verdad
esto es lo mismo que ya transpuesta por
ye donde ya transpuesta porque lo
podemos ver como un vector verdad un
vector que en este caso va a ser
acostadito es decir va a ser este vector
y 1 y 2 así hasta allí n que multiplica
a esta otra matriz de 12 así ya está y
en si hacemos el producto de estas dos
matrices esto nos da el producto punto
de los vectores este es de uno por n y
éste es de n por 1 por lo tanto me queda
un vector de uno por uno así que esta
expresión de aquí lo podemos reescribir
como c x transpuesta x
pero aquí el producto es de matrices ce
x
y otra cosa que hay que recordar es que
significa la matriz transpuesta de un
producto de matrices por ejemplo si yo
tengo a be transpuesta esto será lo
mismo que de transpuesta a transpuesta y
esto ya lo vimos hace ya no se hace
bastantes vídeos pero que nos van a ser
muy útiles para para este caso
entonces la transpuesta de s por x
simplemente será x 3 respuesta de
transpuesta y que luego multiplica hace
x
multiplica
x tenemos esta última multiplicación y
como tenemos que la transporta es igual
a la inversa este producto de matrices
simplemente me da la identidad que para
fines prácticos por la identidad no no
pintan en este juego verdad así que la
podemos omitir y dejar simplemente x
transpuesta por equis verdad y x
transpuesta por x es x punto x que no es
otra cosa más que la norma de x al
cuadrado entonces la norma al cuadrado
de ese x fue la norma de x al cuadrado
quiere decir que las normas son iguales
que coinciden entonces hemos demostrado
que las distancias que las distancias se
preservan ahora veamos que para ángulos
también se cumple y habría que definir
los primero porque sabemos que con todo
lo que llevamos estudiando de
matemáticas entendemos muy bien en en r2
y r3 qué son los ángulos verdad pero en
álgebra lineal hay que hablar en general
así que una d
de ángulos que podemos dar es la
siguiente que si nosotros tenemos el
producto punto de dos vectores esto será
igual esto será igual
esto será igual a la norma debe por la
norma del segundo que es w por el coseno
del ángulo que forman estos dos vectores
muy bien o bien si ya queremos definir
el ángulo de forma propia tenemos que
decir que el coseno del ángulo es igual
a b punto w sobre la norma debe por la
norma de w por supuesto estamos pensando
que b y doble uno son vectores cero y de
hecho pues si tenemos un vector pero no
no podemos definir muy bien un ángulo
verdad y aquí se ve por qué pero bueno
esta es la definición no recuerdo si ya
lo habíamos visto en otro vídeo sí sí
habría que repasar lo y si no voy a
hacerlo próximamente
entonces el coseno del ángulo vamos a
calcular el coste no del ángulo del
ángulo una vez que ya aplicamos la
transformación entonces esto será
de punto cwv entre la norma de estos dos
se ve la norma de cb por la norma de c&w
entonces está con esta definición de
ángulo vamos a ir trabajando de hecho ya
vimos por esta propiedad anterior que la
norma de cb es la misma que la norma
debe y la norma de c&w es la misma que
la norma de w entonces el coseno del
ángulo después de aplicar la
transformación es c de punto c&w sobre
la norma debe por la norma de w muy bien
y ahora bien esto podemos reescribir el
producto punto con esta propiedad que
habíamos dicho verdad lo escribimos como
se ve
se ve transpuesta por cw v sobre la
norma debe por la norma por la norma de
w muy bien y ahora utilizamos esta otra
propiedad de la trans puesta de dos
matrices que esto será igual a b
transpuesta por ser transpuesta por c
por w sobre la norma de d
por la norma de w muy bien y finalmente
cómo se transporta es la inversa de c
aquí tenemos esa propiedad la volvemos a
utilizar entonces esencialmente fue
igual que la anterior esto es ley de la
identidad y esto me queda de transpuesta
punto w sobre normas punto que es en los
puntos simplemente es multiplicación de
matrices pero quizás llaves hacia dónde
voy sobre la norma debe por la norma de
w y que esto es el producto punto ahora
sí debe con w de punto w norma debe
por norma de w muy bien y esto no es
otra cosa más que la definición del
coseno del ángulo pero aquí es el coseno
del ángulo entre b y w sin aplicar la
transformación ce así que cuando
efectuamos una transformación un cambio
de base con una matriz ortogonal de este
tipo de matrices el ángulo entre los
vectores transformados no cambia es el
mismo ángulo que formaban originalmente
antes de ser transformados lo cual es un
resultado que a mí me parece muy bonito
de las transformaciones ortogonales las
transformaciones con matrices
ortogonales no distorsionan vectores si
a lo mejor pueden rotar como en este
como en este ejemplo pero el punto es
que no cambian los ángulos entre ellos